[Music]
how are you guys doing
i'm joined with the esteem
[Laughter]
with the real man with the champ
with the heavyweight champion
what are you talking about yeah too much
tea
too much chili yeah yeah yeah but he
couldn't be here today
[Laughter]
how are you joking man
how are you doing okay well good good to
hear from you good to see you
well we're coming back to the new
atheists you delivered to one of them
maybe seven years ago
um a pretty good spanking
[Laughter]
yeah leo what's his name again leon
krauss what's his first name
i forget lawrence krauss
how do you feel about that debate
you know
[Laughter]
it was good given the circumstances and
my learning at that time
given the circumstances and the learning
my pathway of development at that time
obviously there's many things i think i
could have said that was
more articulate it was better
in terms of the way the audience would
understand it and to
really portray that islam is true and
that atheism is false
but generally speaking i think it was a
very very positive debate
on on balance but i'm going to do a
video in sha allah with
our beloved brother zeshan smile to
jannah on
seven years on from the debate and we're
gonna
do a bit of an assessment and analysis
of it i think that probably was the most
uh popular atheist muslim debate in the
last
30 50 years that i know i think it still
is from a numbers point of view
oh there's no doubt about that so it
would be good to get your insight on
that absolutely but talking about famous
atheists
we wanted to speak about something that
richard dawkins has been coming out
with his dear tai that he comes out with
you know he's got a title
um and speaking about which is ai
artificial intelligence let's just watch
quickly some of the stuff that he said
about
a.i and giving ai robots
rights and then we can comment on that
we reach a profound philosophical
difficulty
i am a philosophical naturalist uh i am
committed to the view
that there is nothing in our brains that
violates the laws of physics there's
nothing that could not in principle
be reproduced in technology it hasn't
been done yet we're probably quite a
long way away from it
but i see no reason why in future we
shouldn't reach the point
where a a human-made robot
is capable of consciousness
and of feeling pain this is profoundly
disturbing because it kind of goes
against the grain to think that uh
that a machine made of metal and
and silicon chips um could feel pain but
i
i don't see why they would not and so
that this
moral consideration of how to treat
artificially artificially intelligent
robots
will arise in the future and it's a
problem which
philosophers and moral philosophers are
already talking about so as you can see
he obviously thinks that on his
worldview materialism
that philosophical philosophical
naturalism that he thinks that
um robots or ai can have conscious
consciousness yes uh and that because of
this
they should be given rights what is your
response to that
well i don't want to go into the whole
rights and
the whole morality stuff okay the reason
being because that is
dependent on your understanding of ai
being conscious
and what do you mean by a.i being
conscious yes and that's why i have my
phone out it was not to be rude because
i have notes on this yeah
the first thing we need to address i
think is richard dawkins says that he's
a philosophical naturalist
now i find that very interesting bro
because
philosophical naturalism is not really
scientific per se and he comes across as
someone who promotes some kind of public
scientism right
that science is the only way to render
the truth about the world in reality
okay maybe that's a hard form of
scientism let's make it a bit more
softer
maybe he says science is one of the best
ways to render the truth about the word
in reality
however philosophical naturalism is more
of a philosophy
rather than anything scientific so he
says he's a philosophical naturalist
what does that mean
that means that there is no divine there
is no supernatural
everything can be explained by physical
processes or reduced to physical things
in some way
now that is very interesting because
that's a faith
remember he says i am committed to now
the atheist the prominent atheist
philosopher
michael rules he says you know if you
want a concession
naturalism is is a faith because you
have to believe it as a lens
uh in order for you to see through in
order to understand the world in reality
so he already comes with the
presupposition
that there is no god he already comes
with the presupposition
that everything can be explained by
physical processes
he that's his starting point those are
his lenses
you know in which he sees through to
understand reality
so he's admitted something here this is
my faith
i'm a philosophical naturalist so
therefore even though i know nothing
about ai
i'm going to assume that ai is going to
be conscious and i'm going to assume
that it must be given rights
that is a really unnuanced ridiculous
way of starting a
a a a video about ai the discussion
shouldn't presume philosophical
naturalism to be true and when you watch
the whole video
you see that really they are presuming
philosophical naturalism to be true
and in the context of ai and
consciousness they're presuming
a physicalist understanding of
consciousness
which basically means that consciousness
can be reduced to or is identical in
some way
to physical processes so how do you
define consciousness and
what needs to be in place for
consciousness to work oh my god
because i think we need to for you know
cover this ground
okay this is a big question but let's
apply it to the ai scenario
so i think what they're trying to say is
that
ai machines or computer programs or
robots whatever the case may be
they are going to be indistinguishable
to human beings in some way
okay when it comes to consciousness when
it comes to
intelligence when it comes to
interaction to the point where richard
dawkins even says
even concerning pain right and this is
the point that we need to zoom in on
we don't have a problem with certain
aspects of consciousness such as
thoughts or you know cognition
or intelligence right because these are
these are connected to consciousness as
well
what we're talking about here is that
can artificial intelligent
machines can they have
inner subjective conscious states
can they have something called
intentionality
okay which is now this is quite broad in
the philosophy of the mind but generally
speaking intentionality means and is
connected to meaning
it means that your
reasoning is about or of something else
okay so say i am reasoning say i'm
reasoning about
muhammad hijab i'm talking about
muhammad hijab and i'm reasoning
reasoning about you i know that i'm
reasoning about something other than
myself and other than the just the
the the sounds and the words that i'm
using it is
of and about something external to me
now we can safely say that robots or am
machines don't have an ability to do
that
because really robots and machines about
just rearranging of symbols right the
symbols
don't know that those symbols are about
or of something external to the symbol
itself
right because fundamentally computer
programs are based on zeros and ones
right
fundamentally so do the zeros and ones
do they know
that they are addressing an entity a
conscious sentient entity called
muhammad hijab
do so do they have intentionality no
it's just zeros and ones and this is
arrangement of zeros and ones
the zeros and ones are not of and about
muhammad hijab or rather the zeros and
ones don't know
they are referring to something called
muhammad hijab that's external to them
right so this is
generally speaking uh intentionality and
it relates to meaning and that's a
really good point that is a good point
but the thing is it's
very vast and there's a lot of
discussions oh that's a good way of
putting it because you're saying that
robots will only be able to interact
with
symbols directly but wouldn't know
wouldn't be able to give meaning to
those symbols
good so this is the point here so
computer systems just manipulate
symbols they can't attach meaning to the
symbol so this is
syntax and semantics so let me give an
example
um the difference between syntax and
semantics so we have here three
sentences right
yeah one in greek one in english
and let's do one in turkish right so
it's i love you
all right which is greek i love you and
you have
seni seville which is i love you in
turkish now as you can see the three
sentences have the same
semantics they have the same meaning but
they have different symbols
so what do we learn from this well take
this if i were to give you
all of the symbols of greek and teach
you how to arrange them
in the correct way with the right spaces
right in the right
kind of grammatical formula whatever the
case may be
by virtue of you doing that would you
know the meaning no
exactly so that shows there's a
difference between just
merely rearranging symbols and
understanding the meaning connected to
the symbols and attaching meaning to the
symbols right
so there's an interesting argument that
i think uh john professor john cell he
developed and i've adapted it here
is number one computer programs are
syntactical
so they're based on syntax number two
minds have semantics
number three syntax by itself is neither
sufficient nor constitutive
for semantics four therefore computer
programs by themselves
are not minds for example just imagine
an avalanche bro
there's an avalanche in some famous
mountains say in the alps in france
right
and the avalanche when it basically
creates its mess all of a sudden you see
rocks
that are arranged and it says you know
my name is muhammad hijab
and i'm over six foot five and i love
wrestling
and i'm a debater right so
now the mere arrangement of those
symbols right
so the mer arrangement of those symbols
does the avalanche
know the meaning no exactly
so the main arrangement of the symbols
itself doesn't give rise to the meaning
so if an if if a c right if if the tide
was coming in and out and as a result of
the tide moving
uh you see an arrangement of sand that
says i love my mother i love my parents
does the sea know the meaning of those
symbols
no so the mere arrangement of those
symbols in a particular way
doesn't necessarily give rise to meaning
because the c doesn't know how to attach
meaning to the symbols and the avalanche
doesn't know how to attach meaning
to the arrangement of rocks that for us
has meaning right
does that make sense um okay so this is
good
so you can't ever prove that do you
think there's ever a chance no sorry so
here's the point the point is
ai machines yeah they're just complex
syntactical arrangements
they can never you're saying that it's
not possible for them to they can't
attach me to
the symbols yeah why not
because of what we just discussed so for
example if an avalanche were to come and
somehow arrange a bunch of symbols that
says
i love smile to jannah it's the best
channel in the world please subscribe
now
yeah right it doesn't know the meaning
of that that's meaningless anyway
but do you see my point yeah so let's
break this down further so your question
really has opened the door to professor
john cell's
famous chinese room experiment you ready
for this experiment yeah okay heard of
this before but just go for it again
yeah so so say this is a room this this
pillow
right can you see this pillow sir
this pillow is a room you are in this
room hijab okay
on the side you're inside you're inside
yeah yeah you're right with that i'm
okay good
so you're in this pillow but it's a
roman we call it the chinese room
in this room there is a rule book but
it's only in the english language
i'm alright yeah and the rule book says
when you see this chinese symbol
and this chinese symbol then you
give this chinese symbol you don't know
what the symbols mean it's just giving
you a
symbolic representation right here are
the chinese characters when you see this
chinese character and this chinese
character then
give us or give outside of the room this
chinese character yeah
okay outside of the room are
chinese speakers for example yeah and
they give you questions okay this is an
adapted version of the thought
experiment but it still works
they give you questions in chinese yeah
so
they don't know who you are but you take
the questions in chinese and you read
the english rule book
and you say okay i've seen this chinese
character i have no idea what it means
but i've seen this chinese character and
this chinese character and the rule book
says i have to give this chinese
character
so you're giving all the right answers
out so for the people outside of the
room
do they think you know chinese yes
exactly
but do you know chinese no exactly so
this chinese room through experiment
represents what happens to the ai
machine
they just have syntactical arrangement
this is a manipulation of symbols
not meaning now there is a response to
this it's called the systems reply john
cell
calls it the systems reply some people
say yeah you
as muhammad hijab may not know the
meaning but the system itself
knows the meaning and john so replies
and says well how can that be the case
because there is no way of the system
attaching meaning to the symbols in the
first place
yeah and you could even extend the
thought experiment by saying that this
whole system could just be in your brain
mr muhammad hijab yeah
you could know how to manipulate all the
symbols
and always give the right answer but
does that mean you know the meaning
of the language no you just know how to
basically put different things together
now for example i could teach you right
now greek right so if someone says
boss ise okay yeah boss is fine
my
[Laughter]
there you go do you know what do you
know what i'm saying yes yes
you don't know what i'm saying yeah so
you just said to me
how are you i said i'm very good how did
you know i just
hey for the audience you know what i'm
saying yeah so i could i
don't know what i was guessing okay
that's a guess exactly so the point here
is
i'm just giving you symbols but in the
form of sounds
and i'm teaching you what sound to give
me back just because you know
the kind of syntactical symbolic
arrangement whether it's written format
or in in in in in in sound in
waves whatever right it doesn't mean you
know the meaning
right meaning so i could train you to
come to my house
my mom's house and she may have like she
may give you like five sentences
right and i could train you to respond
in a particular way that may
make her realize that you think that she
thinks that you know greek to the point
i could we could manipulate the whole
thing and say
after those five sentences and you
responded so well you could say in greek
oh i need to go my mom's calling me uh
yeah so you could escape the rumor
you're not you're not questioning any
further
so the point i'm trying to say is we we
can train you
to come across as knowing greek but that
you have no idea what's going on
you know just by virtue of you've just
arranged
uh you just know the programs you just
you just do you see my point
yes so that's why is that so you said
intentionally
yes so let me just go back into my notes
because there's another response to the
chinese uh room experiment which is very
important for us to
um yeah so so concludes having the
symbols by themselves
just having the syntax is not sufficient
for having the semantics
merely manipulating symbols is not
enough to guarantee
knowledge of what they mean okay
so obviously there is
lots of discussion concerning this issue
in the philosophy of that what's really
interesting in the quran yeah yeah
when when the malaika when the angel
said allah says
he taught adam all the nouns all the
names and then he
and then adam reflected it back to the
angels but the ones who use m
s met give me news literally from neba
give me news of what this these words
are if you are truthful
so it's it's not just regurgitation
it's telling me what this is about it's
about meaning as well
yes well some of the exegetes they even
said that
this is not just labels or terms
and nouns this is also the concept of
things
which is about meaning which is very
very interesting and the abstract nouns
yeah but yanni the kind of exegesis of
the ayah here is it wasn't just that it
was about the concept behind these
things
yeah which is very deep so you know if
you want more information they go to
sapience institute.org go to read and
you go there's answers there's an answer
called
does ai undermine religion we'll put it
in the description yeah
and you've got more information on what
we just spoke about but just to
summarize
you computer programs don't really have
intentionality so ai machines don't have
intentionality
the symbols that they have in their
programming the symbols don't know
that it's about something or of
something outside of the symbol
itself right it's just a symbol and
that is connected to meaning and we know
that computer programs manipulate
symbols not semantics it's syntactical
arrangements not
semantics and we gave the example of the
three
different ways of saying i love you i
love you sargabo
seni severum this has one meaning but
different symbols and if i gave you all
the right symbols of the turkish or
greek language to put them in the right
way
just by virtue of arranging them in in
the correct way to produce
the words equivalent in that language of
i love you you would never know it means
i love you
because you just know the symbols
there's no way of you attaching meaning
to the symbols right
and then you ask me what does it mean
what is meaning which was a very
very deep question and that opened the
door to the chinese room thought
experiment
and the chinese room thought experiment
actually shows that actually
you can manipulate computers manipulate
the symbols
but it doesn't necessarily mean that
they have the semantics right it's not
just it's by virtue you being able to
manipulate the symbols doesn't
mean that you now know the meaning and
this
differentiates between soft ai sorry
weak ai and hard ai
so weak ai is yes computer programs can
be very intelligent
they may even pass the turing test the
turing test is basically this
uh kind of test that was developed it's
like a game
that this computer human being are
having a discussion and there's an
outsider
um that basically needs to try and
differentiate which one's the computer
which one's the human something like
that
but that's not a very good test and
there's a lot of contentions behind it
anyway but the point is you may even
pass the turing test you may talk to an
ai machine and think
it's a normal human that doesn't mean
now that that ai machine
is conscious in the way that we just
spoke about it just means that they're
manipulating the symbols really really
well
even when they're talking about things
like machine learning in ai right
machine learning is just complicated
syntactic arrangements
with more complicates and tactical
arrangements and they're just reduced
fundamentally to zeros on ones which
don't have intentionality right
so yeah so this difference between hard
and soft ai so
soft ai is they could be very
intelligent more intelligent human
beings and we've seen it on popular
media and there's a really good uh
youtube
video by smart janna on you know the
conspiracy of
ai and stuff like that and you see
computer programs can be far more
intelligent than human beings
but that doesn't mean they're conscious
in the way that we just discussed that
they have inner subjective
conscious states that they can feel pain
that they now can attach meaning to
symbols
so if they can't have that type of
consciousness
why are you even talking about rights in
the same way that you talk about human
rights that's my point
so don't come across with the
physicalist philosophical naturalistic
presupposition here that yes one day
they are going to have
uh rights you know what i did say to
zichard a few hours ago i said
in 10 to 20 years you're going to have
people marrying robots
yeah and when you turn a robot off and
with the intention not to turn it back
on kind of thing
it's going to be like murder that's the
gist of our conversation so i think
that's going to happen you had japanese
well nothing wrong with japanese people
but there was a japanese person
he married a manga cartoon a manga
cartoon bro
yeah no no i don't know you don't know
what mega cartoon is this is a cartoon
he married a cartoon anime it's like
anime yeah
would you believe it so there's a
difference between hard ai and soft ai
so soft ais computer programs in air can
be very very intelligent and even it may
even pass the turing test that you could
sound like a human being as sound
conscious
but you will never truly be conscious
because ai machines
there is no such thing as hard ai just
from a philosophical point of view
because of intentionality because of
syntax and the semantics discussion that
we just had
and yes this discussion continues
there's lots of debates on this you know
we're not giving you the fullness
picture
but it's a good starting point for you
to understand that fundamentally
you know you have to understand when you
watch videos like this they come with
some philosophical lenses and
presuppositions
as makuu says the faith of philosophical
naturalism
they have to presume that physicalism is
true
they have to presume that philosophical
naturalism is true and therefore say
yeah
maybe they can become conscious in the
way that we're
discussing and therefore we should give
them rights but before you get there
let's have the real philosophical
discussion can they really be conscious
in the way that you're thinking
is philosophical naturalism true from
this point of view and is physicalism
true as an approach to the philosophy of
the mind and that's the debates that's
continuing
and hopefully giving you some insights
for you to do further research and go to
the
link below or wherever you know to read
a little bit further concerning uh
does ai undermine religion with that
guys
thank you for watching happy birthday
with that guys
make sure you do what the man says
and um go yes go down to the enchanted
description there's lots of things that
come out the book that i've written
called
scientific deception new atheists also
free of charge on the sapiens
institute so make sure you go and
download that is free of charge
i'll put another description a link in
the description for that there are
things that are coming out three of our
webinars that we're doing on a weekly
basis
uh that are free of charge so everything
there is going to be once again free of
charge
so make sure you go and visit that
website
you